[Music]
I'd like to begin with a very personal
anecdote when I was quite young probably
in first or second grade or so we had
what for me growing up in a little town
in West Virginia was a great adventure
my parents took my brother and me to
Washington their nation's capital we
went on the bus it was a long overnight
trip they knew I would be so excited
about this they didn't tell me until the
morning we left and it was really quite
a highlight of my life to get out and
see the big exciting city that's there
nation's capital on the way we drove
through a little town somewhere in
Maryland and the bus pulled up to a
restaurant to stop and let people get
something to eat there was a young black
man who I suppose looking back on it was
probably in his early to mid 20s
carrying his little daughter and when we
stopped that restaurant they would not
serve Him and they would not serve the
little girl and my mother decided that
this was not a reasonable thing and she
had heard what the man had tried to
order for his little girl which was a
bowl of soup so my mother ordered an
extra bowl of soup and the waitress of
course did not refuse her but before she
handed the bowl of soup to my mother she
reached over and just laden it with
pepper and that electric moment has just
always been with me ever since and I
think that was the time at which I lost
some of my naivete about
racial relations in America and so forth
I actually started school in segregated
schools I was educated in public schools
in my hometown and my home state
desegregated at schools just about a
year or two years prior to the Supreme
Court decision but operating under the
same set of social forces so that I was
in about eight through ninth grade at
the time the schools became integrated
and it was kind of a magic moment there
were a lot of things that were not good
about the 50s but growing up as as a
young person in small-town American the
50s was actually a very positive and
wonderful time I look back on and the
new youngsters who came to our school
from what had been previously the
segregated black junior high school and
so forth we're an extraordinary Bunch
I still know where many of them are
today and what they're doing they've
been rather successful in life and for
whatever reason it was a society that
that had a lot of cohesion black and
white despite the fact that we'd grown
up in legally segregated worlds and from
that I just learned that underneath we
are all the same that we have very
common sets of goals and values so it
became very painful to me over time to
see how that society that I got a rather
idealistic view and experience of began
to degenerate and pull apart and in some
ways develop more insidious forces than
we're present when we had crystal clear
and legally enforced segregation and so
those two experiences I think have very
much shaped the way I think about
diverse
in particularly relations between
african-americans and whites in this
country looking toward more recent part
of my personal history that I think is
very relevant to the question of is
there really a value to diversity in an
educational setting in a business
setting and life setting as an engineer
I like to think a lot in terms of
analogies Engineers often draw analogies
between circuits and mechanical systems
and sometimes you can understand one
better than the other but learn the same
lessons as I review my life I think
about my education and particularly my
education in graduate school my thesis
advisor grew up in Turkey came to this
country and earned his doctoral degree
here at MIT as a matter of fact my
closest friend as a graduate student was
a young man who came from India who grew
up in the area around Bombay as I
entered left graduate school and entered
early years as a faculty member two of
my very closest professional and
personal friends one was a Hungarian who
left hungry during the 56 revolt
literally as a as a young freedom
fighter another whose office was next to
me I've remained very close to over the
years as a faculty member and colleague
and friend had grown up in Taiwan spent
much of his life in Japan after the
Second World War and there was never any
doubt about the way in which that
international kind of cultural diversity
brought a richness and the content to my
life personally as well as
professionally that simply wouldn't have
been there otherwise we spent lots of
time in our free moments talking about
the way our different backgrounds that
influenced our perspectives
one of my friends as a graduate student
who also worked for my for the same
Turkish professor as his thesis advisor
I grew up in Finland and if you look at
the history of the Finnish people
they're very closely tied to the same
people who who populated Turkey and we
would spend long hours looking at sort
of the legends and epic poems and so
forth and stories that they knew in
common so these things have always
fascinated me and I draw the same kind
of analogy between that international
multiculturalism that I was so much the
beneficiary of in my years both being
educated and as an educator and I think
that the same thing has to be true as we
look at various racial and ethnic groups
within our own nation so I do
fundamentally believe that diversity is
a good thing and that just as in the the
history of Europe the great flowering of
literature and so forth that that
occurred as the British people and the
French people merged and became one I'm
enough of an optimist to believe that in
time the same kind of thing is going to
happen in this great nation and perhaps
is happening in at least an incipient
way right now so yes I do believe there
is an intrinsic value in in diversity
and learning through different eyes and
listening to the different voices it
sometimes is more difficult to think
about in the context of science and
engineering the professional worlds that
that I have tended to inhabit because
while some would argue that these are
not these are perhaps not subjects that
are totally without political content
and so forth they think by comparison to
other fields of study students who are
involved in science and
tend to have a little more in common and
a little more common focus and direction
to their way of thought and so forth and
in perhaps other other fields and it's
made it a bit easier for us I think to
build a diverse community and and to
work together on the professional level
for many years while I was a faculty
member and ultimately an administrator
at the University of Michigan I was
involved in one way or another with
efforts to recruit minority students to
build educational programs on the campus
and work with groups like the Society of
black engineers and Society of Hispanic
engineers I always considered one of the
fun parts of my job these groups I found
there and I have found in my contacts
here at MIT
certainly as well are among the most
highly motivated and the most self
supportive groups that we have on campus
and I think that's wonderful and I think
the rest of us can learn something from
that and and I hope that I hope that we
do looking in a more pragmatic context
and I don't think we should be afraid to
be pragmatic one also has to recognize
that our society has the makeup that it
has and we know perfectly well within a
timeframe of 20 years or 30 years
exactly what the racial and ethnic
makeup of this country is and on a
pragmatic scale we simply must learn to
live and work in advance together the
historical forces make it a difficult
task the current economic forces make it
an even more daunting set of problems
but if we are to be a great nation in
the future somehow we have to resolve
and and come to grips with it so I think
even in a pragmatic sense as well as a
moral sense we as a leading institution
education and research in the United
States in the 1990s must be dedicated to
educating increasing numbers of students
from the various components of the
American population we must produce from
those communities the leaders that the
nation is going to need downstream in 20
or 30 years so there will be no backing
off of this institutions commitment to
these matters despite the fact that we
are in rather difficult economic times
it's got to be very very high on our
agenda at the same time we must never be
naive about what is involved about the
depth of effort that is going to be
required and as we do with any student
we win these battles and make our
progression one individual at a time by
individuals commitments by what we can
provide to individuals by what we can
learn from them and I hope as a leader
that I can play at least some modest
part in inspiring and and leading our
community on to to undertake this this
very important role I have enjoyed the
contact I have had these last three
years with the students on the MIT
campus my wife and I have made a habit
of roughly every week or so as calendar
permits spending an evening eating in a
dormitory or an independent living group
or what-have-you we've made the rounds
of probably a hundred and some living
situations and the students here just
wonderful and remarkable every group has
its own its own tone but I again must be
honest with you that I never am more
inspired or feel better about our
community than those contacts I have
with with our minority students we've
spent evenings at chocolate city and
deep discussions they've been open and
candid and I come away feeling very good
despite the fact that we know we're
working with
with heart problems occasionally I'm
extremely supportive of and excited
about this video project I think that
the idea of letting each group
communicate and are very natural and
free and open way and then ultimately
merging these together to really show us
the fabric of our student body is
something we're going to learn from I
don't know where it's going to lead I
don't know what the commonalities and
differences are going to be but it's a
it's a true MIT approach to a problem
we're going to get in there and we're
going to learn we're going to get the
the objective data and the viewpoints
and I'm just very excited about it and
think it's really a leadership kind of
activity as you know I have seen the
first video that was made by our
african-american students and there was
at least one immediate lesson and
looking at that which quite honestly
surprised me and that was the fact that
almost every one of the students in
talking about their personal
observations of racial relations and so
forth on the campus from their personal
perspective immediately honed in on the
instructional aspects of MIT almost all
of the anecdotes that they passed on to
the rest of us had to do with classroom
or other learning situations it's very
important for us all to understand it
certainly is important for me to
understand as as an administrator and
leader on the campus the bad news is it
shows problems in the most fundamentally
important aspect of what we do but the
good news is that's something that we
can consciously be aware of and try to
work together as a community to improve
so I see this as a wonderful discovery
and an learning tool and I'm very
grateful to all
you who are participating in the project
one of the things that is clearly true
of American business today is that in
virtually every domain there are no
longer American businesses we talk a lot
in the government and in academia about
the internationalization the
globalization of business frankly it's
happened
I talked to business leaders here in
Boston I can think of the CEO of one
major manufacturing concern whose brand
name everybody would recognize told me
that 12% of their businesses in the
United States right now as I talked to
executives they're more and more making
it clear that the way to advance in
their companies today particularly along
the executive chain is to understand
other nations other cultures know other
languages many corporations are simply
decree that those people on a strong
upwardly mobile track and the company
are going to have to live overseas and
experience an overseas operation for a
while typical US manufacturing companies
today have locations in 20 30 40
different places around the world
sometimes more it's no longer a matter
of is this a good thing to do it's a
matter of you must do it if you're going
to survive and I think that's going to
drive a great opening of the American
mind because of our inherent strengths
our system of government the strength of
our economy over the last 3040 years we
have been incredibly insular and
isolated in many ways we're isolated
geographically and we've been isolated I
think socially and culturally far too
much certainly many of the greatest
experiences my life things that I deeply
value have been opportunities
particularly through my scientific work
in earlier years to associate with
people
across the world and have people I
consider to be good close colleagues in
Asia and Europe and Mexico and other
places that's going to be more than norm
and I think it's going to be enjoyable
and exciting but it's not a luxury it's
something that we have no choice of and
the more that we can help to jumpstart
our students into that world the better
off we will be as an institution and as
a nation and businesses as well one of
the things we're very proud of here at
the Institute is the MIT Japan program
where as you know 50 or 60 of our
undergraduates in a given year have
committed themselves to learning the
Japanese language while they're
undergraduates to taking a sequence of
seminars on history and culture and
business practice and then upon
graduation go to Japan for a year or two
as interns in an industry or a
laboratory or what have you
and come back to this country with that
perspective and and knowledge and
understanding and apply it to our own
corporations we would like to be doing
the same thing in Europe and elsewhere
these are small but very powerful and an
important examples you mentioned the
question of teaching diversity I find
this a very difficult concept to grapple
with I don't know if it is literally
possible to teach diversity in the sense
that one can teach electronic circuits
or calculus or what have you
my suspicion is that we must accomplish
education about multiculturalism about
diversity in our society and our
activities on many different planes and
through many different mechanisms some I
know would disagree with this philosophy
but I find the subject to be so broad
and so complex and so ill-defined that
it is not clear to me that one can
define a single course or a single
curriculum that will satisfy that need
for all people so I think that we need
to think about diversity
multiculturalism understanding history
and sociology and technology and other
subjects from a broad variety of
cultural and racial perspectives in many
different ways I think we have to do it
formally we have to do it informally
this taping project is a beautiful
example dr. Williams course is a good
example Mill Kings course is a good
example I think we have to do this over
and over again in different venues and
different ways to fit different people
and kind of just build up an environment
where nobody gets through the institute
without some informal if not formal
exposure to a disciplined thinking about
other cultures other races there is no
simple answer if I knew it I certainly
would share it and try to to implement
it but I think it's a question we need
to keep in front of us we need to try a
lot of experiments it needs to be part
of what we think of as the hidden
curriculum at MIT in the same way that
professional ethics and and other things
are and I hope over time that we can
make some progress together